leave motivation what's your top plan
with belief nation hates Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you you've got Michael Jordan level
talent at something so get ready to
start with why be a problem solver and
start small with Simon sonic and my take
on his top ten rules of success volume 7
joy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one start with why I discovered that
every single organization on the planet
even our own careers always function on
the same three levels why we do what we
do how we do it and what we do and it's
based on the biology of human
decision-making every single one of us
knows what we do it's the job we have
you know we know that or if the if it's
a company it's the products they sell
the services they offer some can clearly
articulate how they do things the things
that we think make us different or
special or stand out from the crowd but
very few people or organizations can
clearly articulate why they do what they
do and by why I don't mean to make money
that's a result by why I mean what is
your purpose what is your cause what is
your belief why did you get out of bed
this morning
you know why does your company exist and
why should anyone care yeah and what I
learned is all the great leaders those
with the capacity to inspire us
everything from Steve Jobs to Nelson
Mandela regardless of what they do every
single one of them starts with why they
always lead with their purpose and like
I said it's based on the biology of
human decision-making so it's it's not
even my opinion rule number two be a
problem-solver the word entrepreneur is
bandied about too loosely mmm that not
everyone who owns a small business as an
entrepreneur there are small business
owners and they're entrepreneurs what's
don't reproduce and you can find
entrepreneurs in big companies it
doesn't means that there's small
business owners right I think
entrepreneurs are problem solvers
I think rather than risk takers yeah I
think fundamentally there are plenty of
risk takers I think who aren't
entrepreneur there's a risk taker of
your small business owner right you went
out to start the business but they're
not the same
I don't think and entrepreneurs are
those ones who they're constantly
looking to soul
problems and that's where I think they
perceive opportunity or the mischief
that you describe I don't think it's I
don't think inherently it's a sense of
mischief they're not trying to stir the
pot for the sake of stirring the pot I
think that they see something and
they're like we can make that better or
we can fill that hole and that's very
much the way the famous entrepreneurs
the Elon Musk's and the Richard
Branson's operate they see gaps they see
things that don't work as their jobs as
did jobs they see things that could be
better rule number three
start small I had the marketing business
lost my passion for what I was doing
that crisis mm-hmm
was the spark that helped me find this
thing called the Y and then to find the
Golden Circle and I would fell in love
with this idea and would literally go to
my friend's apartments and give talks to
their friends about this thing called
the Y and I would help people find their
Y for a hundred bucks on the side that's
how it began okay and people just kept
in kept asking me to speak and I kept
saying yes so I was actually giving the
talk for about three years before any
book or TED talk and that's when I
abandoned my marketing business because
I realized when I realized I could make
a living doing this that people will pay
me to speak and will also invite me to
come in consult I guess but as it
started to the game popularity then the
question was what do I want to do and I
made the conscious decision not to build
a consultancy because I didn't want for
me
spreading the message was much more
important so I sort of took on the the
the identity of sort of a modern-day
preacher I had a purpose I had a cause I
had a calling I had a something I
believed in that I was gonna preach I
was gonna share it I was gonna stand on
my bully pulpit and I was gonna look for
followers to help me spread this spread
this gospel I mean that's really that
the angle I took and that's what we've
done and the reason the message has
spread is because that's what we decided
we would do rule number four always be a
student I consider myself a student all
these things like I don't even insert
myself an expert in leadership or any of
the stuff that I even write about I
could consider myself a student and
though my learning may be more advanced
than some people yeah I show up every
single day to see what I can learn isn't
that a trait of a great leaders that
they just they never say finished done
I'm a great leader that constantly the
best leaders that I've ever met
don't consider themselves experts they
do they are all sort of they all believe
there's room to grow and no matter how
senior how advanced they they have this
sort of you know childlike curiosity
they don't always agree with everything
but they want to they want to they want
to hear people's ideas yeah and they'll
ear in then they tend to ask a lot of
questions also if you want to have more
motivation self love and confidence
check out my 254 series they're free the
link to join are in the description
below some people see the thing that
they want and some people see the thing
that prevents them from getting the
thing that they want I would rather take
the risk of walking out knowing that I
might get moved in a way that I've never
experienced before more than just go and
have a nice night out and see something
that I know is good but I'm interested
in your opinion let's go around the room
it's too late
rule number five find a vision society
and folks like me put an unfair pressure
on people to have a vision yeah right
and I think that's true we're not all
Steve Jobs we don't all have big
world-changing visions to your point I
do believe however you can find a vision
right in other words it doesn't have to
be yours it can be someone else's we
found Martin Luther King we found
Mahatma Gandhi we found Steve Jobs we
found Richard Branson whoever you Elan
musk the visionaries and people go I
loved his vision so organize your
business around that right you don't
have to have a vision but I do believe
you have to find one people find it in
religion you know you follow whatever
you follow right you you become a
follower of so you can say I believe in
that and we're organizing our our
company around helping to build that
world yeah so I don't believe you have
to have one I do you believe you have to
find one Yeah right and it doesn't have
to always operate at a macro level it
absolutely can operate at a micro level
right it can be the way you raise your
family the way you treat your friends
rule number six learn to delegate
I think the differs between an
entrepreneur who cannot achieve scale
which is different from success you can
make a ton of money but that's not scale
it's just money right versus being able
to cross that little chasm and find that
tipping point where it can really gain
scale is the
ability to let go you know I'd been
chief cook and bottle washer I had done
every job and so when I started needing
help because I could no longer do every
job it and have the time or the energy I
wanted to tell everybody how I used to
do it and have them do it that way
that's that's that's about like
assigning tasks
that's not assigning responsibilities
that's not letting go and it was a slow
uncomfortable process it's not like
tomorrow morning I'm just gonna let go
you know it doesn't it doesn't it
doesn't work that way it's a very
uncomfortable process I assume you you
use the analogy of this is your baby I
assume it's something like when your
kids grow up and leave the house or when
they become old enough to drive and they
gain some independence like we'd like to
tell them what to do what to eat when to
go to bed when to have a shower but you
kind of lose that and some parents
struggle with that and it creates
tension in the relationship with their
kids and some parents slowly embrace
that their kids are adults and and it's
the same kind of transition where you
people come on and you realize that they
care and that they're smart and that
they're good at what they do and that
they want to learn and so they want to
do things they've never done before also
they don't have to be experts in
everything and you let go a little bit
they do an amazing job and you let go
and amazing a little bit late and then
they you let go a little bit and they
screw it all up and you say okay try
again and the more they feel that you
care about their success the more I
started to feel um that I cared about
the success of those around me it became
very easy for me to simply say just take
care of this and whatever happens is
fine in every decision you make I love
rule number seven redefine how you think
about passion a problem with passion you
know people gave me the same stupid
advice do what you love thank you thanks
you know find your passion thank you
like what am I supposed to do with that
advice you know and and what I learned
is is that passion like profit as a
result when we commit ourselves to some
higher purpose some higher cause passion
is the result when we work hard for
something we don't believe in it's
called stress we work hard for something
we do believe in it's called passion
passion is not the entry point is that
the exit point so the question is not to
find your passion or find the thing
you're passionate about the question is
what do you believe who wishes what are
your ideals what are your values and
where are the places in which the those
people are those organizations share
your values share your beliefs who is
articulating a vision of the world that
you would like to live in push yourself
in those directions be around those
people you know align yourself with
those organizations and what you will
find is you show up every day with
passion rule number eight find your
courage I've learned that courage is not
some deep internal fortitude that you
don't dig down deep and find the courage
you know that courage is external
courage comes from the relationships we
have with those around us a partner in
business a personal relationship our
team right that's why what we want to
build good cultures because our team
believes in us which gives us courage to
do difficult things so a trapeze artist
a world-famous trapeze artist would
never try a brand new death-defying act
for the very first time without a net
right now all that courage they did
they're the world's greatest repeat
artists but for the they need at
something external before they do
something very dangerous yeah and it's
the same for the rest of us so when we
have someone who says I believe in you I
got your back even if this doesn't work
out I'm here with you rule number nine
just do your best people would come up
to me and say how are you gonna do
another TED talk as successful as the
first one and the answer was I'm not
that was an accident I won the lottery
like I won the lottery and I can't plan
to win the lottery again like that's not
how it works and the success of start
with Y again like I can't plan that like
I there's nothing you can't plan for
something that was an accident so I had
actually completely divorced myself of
any notion that I had to produce
something that was better or more
successful than the first work and so
when I set out to write leaders eat last
the only goal was to share every lesson
that I'd been learning on the topic of
trust and cooperation
and do the best job I can of
communicating those ideas with literally
no concern or thought whether it would
be more successful than the first one I
didn't mind I didn't care and I feel
that way about all my work which is you
know the Y has sort of gone off and done
its own thing and and it's like my kid
living the house I'm like I'm just so
proud
I'm rule number ten the last one before
a very special bonus clip is be a real
team player that teams work in the same
place good teams work together Davis
says so much you know the word team is
so bandied about so easily like this is
my team it's like no you just happen to
work in the same office you know you're
assigned to the same product but do you
love each other do you trust each other
do you care about each other will you
sacrifice for each other are you do you
take real joy and seeing your friends
your colleagues your teammates have a
success or are you bitter and angry that
they got promoted before you you know
does it do you mind that you sometimes
don't get the credit you know that's a
real team there's real love there the
rest I think are just colleagues now I
have a special bonus kept on assignment
on how to find your creative process
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that is time with a three-point
landing question it does go from just
watching the video to taking action here
we go question number one where do you
need to just do your best number two
what do you need to delegate this week
and number three what big idea can you
just start small on today and if you
promise to take action after watching
this video we don't just watch videos
anymore we do something after watching
them give me a hash tag believe down the
comments make that promise to yourself
and then get to work I'm very envious of
writers with discipline you know who
treated like a job from 9:00 to 5:00 or
set a goal every day of writing you know
whatever a thousand words 2,000 words
and they do that I that's not my process
my process is best defined as days of
guilt and self-loathing mm-hmm
punctuated by hours of sheer brilliance
and the problem is I don't know when
those hours will strike and so I will
sit at home and watch TV and hate myself
for not getting any work done and
and I won't go out for dinner in case
one of these things strikes and then I
sit at home and watch TV and say I
should have gone out for dinner and only
see my friends and then the next night I
got for dinner and then I have an idea
and I'm riding on tablecloths and it's
it's more of a creative mad process than
it is a disciplined process
if you want more salmon time I checked
at the top 50 rules video I made on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there some
people see the thing that they want and
some people see the thing that prevents
them from getting the thing that they
want success is a feeling